cheaters never prosper or do they hi
Perkins seems to think so because it's
giving ps4 owners cheat codes with the
save wizard which kind of resurrects the
days of the game shark and game genie
you can max out your money items stats
or jump to level 99 in an instant if you
really want that extra edge in the
single-player games or want to have a
little extra fun I think it'd be worth
it but let's get into how the save
wizard works and what it's capable of
[Music]
before we dive in make sure you're
subscribed to GameSpot to keep up with
game tech where we break down the text
that drives the games we love the save
wizard isn't an actual physical product
rather it's a piece of software you
download for a Windows PC that'll cost
you 60 bucks however you will need a USB
storage drive to transfer save data
between your PC and ps4 so how does it
work simply plug in the USB Drive into
your ps4 select which save files to copy
take it out and plug it into your PC
that has the save wizard installed and
the program will automatically detect
ps4 save files from here you'll pick and
choose from a variety of preset cheats
and apply them to the save file then you
import those files back into your ps4
and overwrite the save that's on your
ps4 save wizard also has an option to
backup the original files in case
something goes wrong
or if you get a guilty conscience it's
currently only functional on Windows PCs
but hypercam is working on a version for
mac and linux it's extremely easy to use
but what can you actually do to your
games the save wizard only goes as far
as modifying discrete quantities like
money or ammo and whether or not you
have access to a certain thing in a game
like spells or abilities there is no god
mode infinite stamina or unlimited items
or anything like that for example the
only cheat available for Metal Gear
Solid 5 phantom pain is to max out GMP
and for blood-borne you can only max all
your blood vials some games have tons of
options though like neo where you can
grant yourself max gold weapon
proficiencies or smithing materials as
long as you have one in your inventory
these are all still super helpful for
those who just want a path of less
resistance in these single-player
campaigns
I put the save wizard to the test myself
with a game that stole my heart this
year persona 5
I followed the steps just as I explained
and within minutes save wizard conjured
up 10 million yen for me imagine being a
high school student fallen out on 10
million yen though I also activated max
experience points for all the characters
and my equip personas but in order for
this to occur I had to finish a battle
and gain some XP afterward everyone's
level shot up to 99 the quick leveling
of social stats set everything to 4 and
required me to do an activity that
boosts the stat before it max out at 5
another option is to get every persona
in the compendium and every one of them
would set to level 1 so I'd have to use
the XP to actually make use of this
there is a trophy to fill out the
persona compendium but it wasn't given
to me despite using the chief which
tells me you can't directly cheat your
way to trophies there are some notable
games missing from the roster
uncharted 4 and horizon zero dawn came
to mind when I first got to use the save
wizard but their absence means that even
high profile games might not have cheat
codes available and of course there
aren't any cheats for multiplayer games
so you won't see the likes of overwatch
or titanfall - no one's going to let you
cheat in an online game anyway you can
actually check out every game and cheat
code that the save wizard has to offer
on its site currently there are 120 plus
games with profiles for the save wizard
and it will be continually updated every
game is going to have its own set of
cheats and circumstances to actually use
these cheats so you might want to put a
little forethought into the implications
of using these cheat codes you're not
caught off guard on how it changes your
game from my experience I didn't
encounter anything game breaking and the
software worked as advertised well I'm
not really inclined to use cheat codes
and games anyway it's pretty sweet that
hyper King gives you the option in a
fairly straightforward manner but keep
in mind you have to shell out 60 bucks
how do you feel about using cheat codes
and games offline make your voice heard
in the comments give this video a thumbs
up and if you're not subscribed to our
channel here at GameSpot threw yourself
a favor and subscribe as always thanks
for watching and we'll see you next time